c'est quand même toute une histoire en
Mauricie des résidents essaient de
récupérer des vaches qui se sont
échappées de leur enclos l'été dernier
Amélie bonsoir vous avez piqué notre
curiosité le troupeau on parle d'un
certain nombre de vaches quand même et
dans la nature depuis des mois et c'est
des cowboys de Saint-Tite qui sont venus
à la rescousse
scénario de film on parle d'une
vingtaine de vaches qui vivent dans le
boisé juste derrière moi depuis le mois
de mai parce qu'à ce moment là il y a eu
des vents violents qui ont endommagé
leur enclos elles ont pris la poudre
d'escampette le terrain était scarpé
vous le voyez sur les images on voit des
vaches aussi ce sont d'autres vaches qui
appartiennent au même propriétaire donc
les très difficiles de les récupérer il
y a un ruisseau une forêt assez dense et
donc un certain moment les vaches se
retrouvaient dans la voie publique la
municipalité a contacté le MAPAQ le
ministère de la faune la Sûreté du
Québec la SPA tout le monde se relance
la balle à un certain moment on a
suggéré à la municipalité d'abattre les
bêtes mais pas question d'aller dans
cette direction alors on a décidé de
faire appel au Festival Western de
Saint-Tite et assez cowboy donc 8
cowboys qui sont venus sur place qui ont
tenté de récupérer les bêtes pendant une
journée complète mais qui n'ont pas
réussi à la toute dernière minute les
bêtes se sont enfui on peut écouter le
maire ainsi que le chef de cette
pouvait pas intervenir tenter aussi
longtemps qu'il restait sur les terres
de privé des gens des agriculteurs
lorsque les animaux ont commencé à
sortir les bêtes ont commencé à sortir
sur la rue ils mettent en danger nos
citoyens donc on était intervenu à ce
moment-là
on est descendu une gang de Chanel avec
les chevaux puis les remorques puis on a
on a réussi à regrouper le troupeau de
hache est environ de vingtaine de vaches
par contre le maïs avait prêté battu
encore puis ils sont arrivés dans un
grand champ de maïs qui devait avoir
trois kilomètres de long par un demi km
de large plus on les aurait échappés
ils ont perdu les cowboys ils ont perdu
dans le champ parce que c'est trop grand
bon mais on rit là mais l'hiver on a les
chevreuils vous avez des vaches
extraordinaires l'hiver
il peut qu'est-ce qui mange là ça pose
plus ils vont avoir faim et les vaches
avec la rareté de la nourriture parce
que tous les thés ils ont vécu la belle
vie dans les champs de maïs d'ailleurs
ça a causé des dizaines de milliers de
dollars de dommages en dans le secteur
ici donc les gens étaient quand même
assez mécontents et là avec le temps
froid on pense qu'on va être capable de
les attirer avec de la nourriture mais
il faut faire attention parce que ce
sont des bêtes qui ont repris des
comportements sauvages on peut écouter
justement un producteur de lait
un peu partout
sont plus aptes à redevenir Sauveur
et peut-être plus heureux en tout cas
mais là ça c'est une des bas sur le
confort des animaux ok mais un sujet
sérieux tout à fait Amélie merci c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous parler merci
vous êtes à Saint-Sever en Mauricie à la
prochaine